So what exactly is a function?
We've mentioned that functions group together blocks of code to perform a specific task,
and we've actually been using functions throughout this course.
Whenever you've used system.out.println to print a line,
you've been calling the function println,
which is a built in Java function.
And calling a function is just referring to
that function by its name and using it in a program.
And you can call the same function as many times you want in a program.
Think of when we've written multiple println lines of code.
Each of these is a function call,
and every time you make a function call,
Java will recognize the name of the function and it will
look inside its own code for a function definition with the same name.
We'll get more into the difference between function
calling and function definitions in a bit.
Function definitions include the name of
function and all the code that function contains.
When you call a function,
like when you say, system.out.println,
it's equivalent to executing all the code in the definition of println.
So when you call println over and over again,
all these calls will refer to the same one function definition.
Java will see a call like this and then look to
the definition to execute the code inside of this function.
So let's check out this definition.
Here's the function definition for printing a line.
It contains several lines of code that worked to display a message on our screen.
And actually this is only a portion of the code included in println.
You can see that its definition starts out with these words,
public and void and then the name of our function println.
Then it takes in a string which we input and then it has
curly braces that grouped together all the code that println and executes.
This block of code is pretty big and quite complicated.
Here we see an if statement that's checking if our string x is equal to null,
and null basically means that it doesn't exist.
So this checks that there is a string to print.
Then there's a lot more code to correctly display the string.
It even uses more functions inside,
like this write function to display our string to our screen.
Just imagine if we had to write this code over and
over every time we wanted to display a message.
Luckily since println is a function,
we're able to use all this code as many times as you want just by
referring to the function name with a function call.
So function calls like this,
let us print stuff out to our screen and we don't need to
know the specifics of the code being executed.